This episode is made possible by the realistic online game war under check out
this game through the link in the description below and going through our link,
not only helps you support this show,
but it also gets you a free premium tank or aircraft,
and three days of premium time. There's a bonus and let's get into it
With that boyish face, slick hair, slight frame and pouty lips.
Oy Murphy could have easily been one of those heart throbs from the James Dean
era, a rebel without a cause of film star, or a pop recording artist.
He was in fact, all of these things. And then some oy Murphy was the real deal.
One who could talk the talk and walk the walk aged belly 21 second.
Lieutenant Audi Murphy had fought his way from north Africa to France in world
war II,
becoming the most decorated soldier in us history and a badass access killing
machine in today's biographics video.
We're gonna take a look at the life of Audi Murphy and how he went to hell and
back.
Audi Leon on Murphy was born on the 20th of June, 1925 in Kingston,
hunt county, Texas in a family of poor sharecroppers of Irish descents.
He did not have an easy life to start with.
Audi had to share her home with 11 siblings with no abundance of food on the
table.
Audi father Emett was not a model dad by any means neglecting to provide for his
wife, joie bell and their 12 children.
Young ODI felt a strong responsibility to care for his family.
And he quit schools an early age managing to complete only fifth grade.
He went to work in the Texas cotton field Z earning a reputation as an
indefatigable cotton picker,
which was well rewarded with the princely pay of $1 a day,
which is about $18 in today's money.
We don't know who his employer was at this time,
but I'm just gonna call him stingy bastard.
There was little food that you could buy with that kind of money.
So oy had to resort to additional means of sustenance at the age,
in which kids in the us and nowadays hunting for cute critters on the Pokemon go
app ODI Murphy went hunting for cute critters with his right squirrels,
rabbits and other small game fell his shots and then fell onto mum Josie's
kitchen workshop.
The experience enabled Murphy to develop great marksmanship skills,
which would later prove useful against another type of prey.
Growing into his teenage years.
Audi looked for other odd jobs working as a shop clerk and a gas station
attendance.
I expect the pay was pro be a bit higher than a dollar a day at this point,
but things went from bad to worse.
When in 1940 Emett Murphy up sticks and deserted his family A's mother
JOC bell died of pneumonia.
The following year suddenly OTI felt the weight of his family's welfare on his
narrow and frail shoulders.
When the us were dragged into world Wari by Japan,
surprise attack on Pearl Harbor on the 7th of December, 1941,
Ory Murphy thought, that's what I'm gonna do. I will join the military.
He saw this not only as a means to provide for his siblings,
but also as a way to honor his mother's memory.
But those elite cause they turned him down due to his tive size and his weak
frame.
Ody in fact stood at only five foot five and weighed him mere 110 pounds.
That's 166 centimeters and 45 kilos,
but he wasn't going to accept such a setback lying down.
It took him seven months,
but he was able to gain 12 pounds in weight armed with his added bulk and his
sister's false testimony that he was 18. He was actually 17.
He was finally inducted into the military, not into the Marines,
his arms force of choice though, but rather just into the regular infantry.
After basic training at camp Walter's, Texas and advanced training at Fort Mead,
Maryland Ody was assigned to the famous 15th infantry S and shipped off to north
Africa. The 15th landed in French Morocco in November of 1942,
as part of operation torch.
This consisted in attacking from the west, the access forces in north Africa,
oh,
while the British and Commonwealth forces were squeezing the ital Germans from
the east. This was the first campaign in which American forces,
which engaged the access on lands. After initial setbacks at the cap,
serene passed the allied divisions slowly but surely encircled the it German
armies in Tunisia. They eventually surrendered on may the 13th, 1943.
During the T campaign. OTTI Murphy did not see combats,
but this was about to change.
His first experience of actual fighting occurred after the allied invasion of
Sicily in July of 1943 in a skirmish against Italian soldiers,
Murphy put to good uses, natural hunting talent and shot dead. Two offices.
This action earned him.
The first of many battlefield promotions becoming a corporal during the Italian
campaign,
OTI consistently impressed his superiors thanks to his courage and innate
leadership skills. On one occasion, he was hit by a German sniper on the hip.
He did not lose his cool and he returned fire hitting the sniper between the
eyes,
but the only photos that managed to hold him back in Italy were mosquitoes.
As he spent much of the time in a field hospital due to several bouts of malaria
in August of 1944 Audi and the 15 threats were in Southern France as part of
operat. Trago one day bought and his units, which included his best friend,
LATI Tipton were blurred out of their foxhole by a group of surrendering
Germans. It was a trap. One of the Germans shot at LATI killing him.
OTI simply went berserk.
He charged at the German squad and wiped them all out single handedly.
He then grabs their heavy machine gun and grenades and put them to good use
attack. Several more German positions,
killing all the enemy soldiers in the area Murphy received his first important
decoration, the distinguished service cross in recognition of these actions.
This was a consistent trait of Murphy's.
He would charge into battle in the most desperate circumstances,
always emerging alive.
Albe not unscathed after inflicting tremendous damage to the enemy,
thanks to his nerves of steel and excellent marksmanship as a reward Murphy not
only collected an impressive number of medals,
but he also escalated in the ranks by January, 1945.
Aged barely 20 Audi had moved from private to corporal,
to sergeants to second Lieutenant. It was on the 26th of that month.
That second Lieutenant Audi Murphy performed the action that would make him a
legend for the years to come in. The early afternoon of that day,
Murphy was leading a platoon of some 40 us troops in a clearing near the French
town of halve close to the German border.
The unit was charged with holding a roadway until reinforcement arrived,
but the relief force did not material realized. And just after 2:00 PM,
the worst happens 250 German troops supported by six tanks and Aus Hillary BARR
emerged from the woods and attacked Murphy's first instinct was to get his meant
to safety. And so he instructed them to withdraw,
to dug in defensive positions along and nearby tree line. As they ran for cover,
he stayed behind and used his field telephone to call in an artillery strike.
He managed to do so just in time before the Penas opened fire against
disposition,
destroying a machine gun nest and setting an American tank destroyer on fire.
But if there's something us soldiers can rely upon its their artillery in a few
seconds, BARR of shells exploded between Murphy and the Germans, the open field,
which had been covered in imaculate snow a few minutes before was now hellish
landscape of craters Murphy took advantage of the cover offered by the barrage
and retreated of the burning tank destroyer. Over the radio,
the artillery commander asked him how close the Germans were to his position.
He replied just hold the phone and I'll let you talk to one of the bastard
squad.
After squad of Germans seemed intent on having a chat on the phone with the
artillery gun.
But Murphy had found out that the fifth caliber machine gun on top of the tank
destroyer was still operational. He quickly opens fire burst after burst,
mowing down dozens of Nazi soldiers,
all the while directing artillery fire over the radio German gunner fought back
with small arms and tank fire with the shrapnel of one blast wounding Murphy in
the leg as usual, he kept on fighting.
It was only when the ammo on the machine gun ran out.
That Murphy finally jumped from the flaming tank destroyer and went back to his
men.
He later wrote that his only thought while retreating was how come I'm not dead
Murphy had now reached safety behind the defensive positions set up by his men.
He had personally killed or wounded about 50 enemies and taken out dozens more
indirectly than the artillery strike, but he wasn't done yet.
Murphy refused to be evacuated from the battlefield and instead rallied his
company into counter attacking the Germans.
Finally driving them back into the woods.
Second Lieutenant Audi Murphy was awarded the medal of honor for his actions at
hots fair, the official citation,
which came with his medal reeds Murphy's indomitable courage and his refusal to
give an inch of ground saved his company from in settlement and destruction and
enabled it to hold the woods, which had been the enemy's objective.
Oy had now become something of a celebrity among the allied troops and his
commanders would rather have him as a liaison officer rather than having him
risk his life on the front line.
The last weeks of the war were relatively peaceful for him.
Not that he needed to see more action by the eDay oy Murphy had endured three
wounds and a nasty case of malaria had been promoted three times from private to
officer had personally killed wounded or captured 240 enemy
soldiers and had received a total of 33 decorations from the us
French and Belgium militaries,
making him the most decorated soldier of world war II.
But he had also lost his best friend, bla as well as camp other army buddies,
as he reflected immediately after the war, there is VI day without,
but no peace within. Now, if you want a fun of battle without, you know,
the real death and horror, well, you should absolutely check out war thunder.
War thunder is a realistic free to play military vehicle combat game war
Thunder's available on PC PS4 and Xbox one.
And you don't need to have all of these consoles.
You just need to have one and there's also no need to purchase war thunder.
You can just download it and play straight away in this game.
There are over 1,200 historically accurate vehicles all the way from 1920
to the 90 in nineties,
they're all carefully built and incredibly detailed and all the physics has
really been sweated over. So it's really very,
very good plus the sound is also amazing. And look,
you can just jump in for a quick arcade game useful if you don't have much time
or you can play realistic for a more challenging tactical situation,
or if your hardcore you can play simulator,
if you're like being destroyed all the time.
So join us on the battlefield for free using the link below doing that.
Not only help support this show, which is cool,
but your SI at a free premium tank aircraft and three days of premium time as a
bonus just for registering and let's get back to Audi
Discharge from the army on September the 21st,
1945 with the rank of first Lieutenant, Ody had barely made it back home.
When Hollywood actor in pre J said,
James Cagney noticed his photo on the cover of a magazine Cagney was a real
Hollywood legend who had become an Alister in the 1930s.
Thanks to his roles in gangster movies.
Cagney had an eye for recognizing talent and immediately noticed in O's boyish
face a certain star quality.
This was a turning point in OTTI Murphy's life and was Cagney, right? Well,
not really, at least at the beginning,
his company Cagney productions paid for acting dancing and Allian lessons.
But in the following years, Murphy struggled to make his big break,
managing to score only two minor roles in beyond glory and Texas,
Brooklyn and heaven, both in 1948.
If there is something we should have learned about Murphy by now though,
is that he's not easily discouraged. The following year,
1949 was a momentous one for him after much auditioning.
He finally got his first lead role as a juvenile delinquent and bad boy fun fact
here, the film's director,
Kurt Newman was more famous for directing the tar zone series with Johnny vice
LERN was a German from Nurenberg. This was probably ABI awkward.
In addition filming with Newman Audi fair on time to publish his war memoir to
hell him back written in a direct style in the present tense Murphy's book does
not hold back from the most atrocious realities of modern war.
It would eventually become a best seller last but not least.
1949 was also the year in which Audi got married.
Just like CGNI had noticed Murphy on a magazine cover.
Oy had noticed his future wife actress won Hendrix on the front page of cornet.
Her beauty apparently had the same effect as being shell by a Panza Audi
insisted to arrange a meeting with hers after a short engagements in 1948,
the two got married on they the February,
1949 and went on to act together in a Western film called era in 1950 in 1951
already had the opportunity to be directed by one of the greatest directors of
all time. John Houston in MGMs the red badge of courage.
This is now considered a classic,
but at the time it bombed at the box office as a result Murphy.
Now under binding contract with universal international pictures was assigned to
star in a string of low to medium budget westerns,
which was the genre which suited best what he's acting talent,
especially his easygoing image and Texas draw, which I'm not going to try.
And in the date he acts in a total of 44 films being the main star in 39 of
them. Despite most of these films having been forgotten by now,
it gave Murphy the opportunity to work with Hollywood royalty, such as actor,
Jimmy Stewart, the directed Don Sieg of dirty Harry fame. However,
the role which he is best remembered is as himself, 1955,
in fact saw the release after to Helen back adapted from his own war memoir,
in which OTI Murphy, the actor start as OTI Murphy.
The war hero to Helen back was a box of success and it remained Universal's most
profitable picture for 20 years until jaws by Spielberg was released.
It consecrated his status as a successful actor and a household name. However,
it forced him to relive the most traumatic experiences of his service in world
war II.
Now I have to apologize as if I've made you think that Odys life was all fine
and DDY after returning from Germany,
it wasn't lieutenants Murphy had brought back with him,
the demons of what has been called shell shock later,
combat fatigue and nowadays posttraumatic stress disorder or PTSD and Murphy
displayed all the typical symptoms of this condition, including nightmares,
extreme anxiety, irritability, and insomnia.
This is how Audi described the agony and misery that he felt it is as though a
fire has ROED through this human house leaving only the chart Hawk of something
that was once green.
He woke up screaming at night and slept with a loaded caliber 45 pistol nearby.
He had a violent Emper so much so that in a bar fight,
he indicted such injuries on his opponents that he was almost convicted have
attempted murder Don Siegel, who directed him in the gun runners in 1958,
reported that Ory often carried a gun on set with many of the cast and crew
being afraid of him.
His marriage with Wanda Hendrick suffered greatly from his disorder.
Ody was often beset with flashbacks and paranoia in the first month after the
wedding and often held wonder at gunpoint during violent episodes.
This must have degenerated in pathological jealousy as Murphy demanded that his
wife by then a much more successful actress than he was give up her job to be a
stay at home.
Wife wonder was frightened by this behavior and left him after only seven months
of marriage charging him with mental cruelty,
the final decree of divorce that came on April the 14th,
1950 Murphy married again. The following year to Pamela Archer. Also an actress.
This union would be a happier one lasting into Lord's death,
but its troubles with insomnia and depression.
They continued throughout the 1960s in parallel with his declining film career
in the, and he became addicted to a powerful prescription drug called PLA Adil,
which can actually worsen preexisting depression.
OTI Murphy though was never one to raise a white flag realizing he had become
addicted to the drug.
He locked himself in a motel room for a week while he went full cold Turkey and
fought back withdrawal symptoms.
He ended up beating the addiction and went on to break the taboo of talking
about the mental disorders that many soldiers suffered from when they returned
home, his willingness to do so.
It opens up for the first time nationwide discussions about psychological care
for Korean and Vietnam war veterans upon their return to the United States.
Meanwhile,
the studio system that Murphy grew up in as an actor had crumbled universals,
new owners,
MCA turned the studios focused towards the now more lucrative television
industry for the AAL productions.
It dropped its roster of contract players and hired act is on a per picture
basis.
Only what this meant for Murphy is that he now had to audition and hustle for
each role, just like at the beginning of his career,
this was made even more difficult by the fact that the traditional mid budget
westerns that had become famous for, they were now a thing of the past,
the 1960s. They were the age of counterculture in the frontier.
It was now represented by a new wave of European made spat T westerns.
What he tried to hand at the new genre landing,
the leading role in the Texan in 1966,
which is more precisely a Pella Western as the majority of the cast was Spanish.
Apparently it is not as terrible as it sounds,
but it did tank the box office as a soldier. He gone as 33 medals as an actor.
The only official accolade was a 1955 prize as movie dis distributor's favorite
Western act app. Fortunately Murphy had diversified his activities,
also becoming a rancher and a businessman in the trade of breeding and selling
thorough bread horses.
He also had become a songwriter writing the lyrics to any pop and country song
hits of the 1960s. His most famous song,
shutters and boards was recorded by legendary kruer Dean Martin among others,
and was even covered in Sweden.
It is easy to find the lyrics and echo of the failed romance with Wanda.
Here are some lines, obviously we'd love to play a few, but you know,
copyright and stuff like that.
It goes shutters and boards cover the windows of the house where we used to
live. All I have left is a heart full of sorrow since she said, never forgive.
The house that we built was once filled with laughter,
but I changed that to laughter and tears.
Now I must live in a world without sunshine. Oh, how I wish you were here
On may the 28th,
1971 Murphy was flying on a private plane on his way to a business meeting,
according to many accounts. By this point,
he at largely lost dis to gambling and bad investments.
Perhaps this meeting was set to get him back on track, but we'll never know.
The plane ran into thick fog over Craig county, Virginia near Roanoke,
and it crashed into the side of a mountain Ody and all five passengers and crew
were killed.
He was buried with full military honors at Arlington on June the seventh.
According to cemetery records,
the only grave side visited by more people than that of Murphy is out of
president John F. Kennedy. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We got brand new videos just like this four times per week.
So subscribe hit that notification bell. Why not? And as always,
I'll see you next time.